hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a scottish mystery thriller
film called marionette spoilers ahead
watch out take care and wait for the
massive plot twist in the end
at the beginning of the film we are
introduced to ten-year-old manny he
doesn't like to talk to people and often
keeps to himself the only thing manny is
interested in is drawing he likes to
draw dark obscure pictures of accidents
and events his personality added with
his hobby makes people think he is a
freak his mother often brings him to
therapy to help him overcome an unsaid
past trauma most therapists think the
drawings are just a way for manny to
relieve stress but it couldn't be
further from the truth the scene cuts to
an american woman named marianne winter
arriving in scotland she is an
experienced psychiatrist who has come
here to start a new life because of an
undisclosed tragedy that happened back
home although in a new place and around
new people marianne doesn't seem to be
hopeful or happy the first visit she
makes is to her workplace where she is
welcomed by a co-worker named moore the
kind lady shows her the counseling room
she will be working in maura is confused
as to why marianne chose to come to
scotland when she had a much better job
back in new york to cut the conversation
short marianne simply says that she
likes the rain the facility is short
staffed after their previous
psychiatrist was hospitalized for a
mental problem hence marianne only gets
a few hours before her first session
with the patients she has two sessions
that day but the second one is far more
interesting than the first the patient
is manny who likes to draw dark obscure
pictures of accidents and events most of
his drawings depict a pig in place of
humans which marianne thinks is
interesting she tries making small talk
with manny but he is busy drawing for
half of the session so she takes a
different approach and starts talking
about the drawing for the first time
manny speaks and claims that no one
likes when he talks so he prefers
staying quiet on being asked why people
feel that way he replies that he can
make things happen intrigued marianne
asks him what was the last thing he made
happen to her surprise he replies
you the comment doesn't make sense to
the doctor but she fails to realize that
the kid isn't just blabbering after work
marianne goes to a bar for a drink she
comes across a man who seems to be
interested in her but doesn't approach
her the man is with a girl who happens
to be marianne's new colleague she hands
marianne a brochure of a book club she
and her guy friend attend and invites
her to join the club a while later
marianne is on her way home when she
comes across a car crash under a tunnel
the car is on fire and the man
underneath it is injured but not dead
marion wants to help him but she freezes
in shock and cannot move at all
eventually it explodes and the
passers-by can do nothing to save the
guy the scene abruptly cuts to the next
day marianne finds a bunch of manny's
drawings one of them depicts a car crash
similar to the one she witnessed
yesterday except there is a pig present
on the scene in the next therapy session
she asks the kid if he saw the car crash
on the news and remembered it manny says
that he didn't see anything about the
car crash in fact he is the one who made
it happen he also adds that he makes
everything happen in this world and if
it weren't for him she wouldn't be here
they confused marianne looks at him in
awe when he claims that there is a gun
in her drawer she dismisses the comment
as him just trying to be spooky and she
doesn't bother to check the drawer
either later that day the staff of the
clinic organized a monthly meeting to
talk about their patients marianne is
told that she is the only person manny
speaks to and is otherwise always quiet
he refuses to talk to his adoptive
mother and his friends as well manny was
previously treated by a doctor whose
position marianne took in the office she
wants to study the case file from the
former doctor and the administration
promises to look into it in the evening
marianne goes to the book club she was
told about as a group discussion takes
place the handsome guy from the bar
catches her attention after the
discussion she introduces herself to him
the guy's name is kieran and he lives in
the same neighborhood as marianne the
two talk briefly before marianne gives
him a ride to his home kieran takes a
step forward and invites her in but
marianne quickly declines at night she
dreams of the time she was in america
with her husband josh they were an ideal
and happy couple driving to a cafe one
day when their car broke down they asked
for help from a man passing by in his
vehicle everything was going well until
they drove off the road and hit a tree
in the accident everyone died except for
marianne the recurring nightmare wakes
marianne and she goes to the office
again to work and get her mind off the
dream to her surprise she finds a gun in
the drawer that manny was talking about
yesterday before she can comprehend what
is going on she gets a call from a man
asking her to kill him before he kills
her the person cuts the call abruptly
leaving marianne confused in the
following scene she meets karen and
chats with him the guy owns a boat so
the two decide to sail for fun he asks
her about the wedding ring and finds out
about her husband's death marianne also
reveals that she came to scotland to run
away from all the haunting memories but
so far it doesn't seem to be working the
next day at work marianne tells her boss
about the strange call she received
yesterday the man assumes it must be
from the former employee of the clinic
mcvitty he was the psychiatrist working
on manny's case before being admitted to
a mental asylum for being delusional
since most of his reports on manny were
affected by his mental health problems
the director refuses to provide his
final notes still he provides marianne
with all the background information
about the kid it turns out manny's
father died in a car crash and his
mother committed the unthinkable right
after he was found in his house severely
malnourished and sick since then he has
made great progress and is now living
with his adoptive mother marianne looks
at the drawings again and they seem much
more disturbing to her after knowing
what he has been through in the
following session manny asks her if the
gun scared her marianne is shocked but
she pretends to not know what he is
talking about this angers manny and this
time he draws a drowning man and writes
the name kieran underneath it marianne
is in utter shock because she and kieran
had decided to go sailing later today
moreover the kid was never told about
kieran after the session ends marianne
finds out that the former doctor mcvidy
developed an obsession with manny and
used to spend a lot of his time in the
library out of curiosity she looks at
the book he read and finds a note inside
it it says that manny's full name
emmanuel means god is with us later she
visits manny in his home and asks him
how he knew about kieran when the kid
refuses to reply she loses her temper
which gives the kid a panic attack
marianne notices a disturbing drawing he
has made and runs away quickly then she
goes to meet kieran for their trip but
he is nowhere to be found marianne is
already scared about his safety after
the drawing of the drowning man manny
showed her she waits for him in her car
for an hour but he never shows up after
that she goes to the book club and then
to his apartment both with no results
upon returning home she watches the news
that says that more than 2 500 people
have died in the flood that occurred a
few hours ago she freaks out and goes
through manny's drawings to find a
picture of a flood with the number 25
written on top manny left out a couple
zeros he's a phony confirmed the next
day in the office marianne is determined
to find out more about manny she breaks
into her boss's office and is seconds
away from finding the notes before her
boss catches her red-handed he has also
been informed about marianne's trip to
manny's house he asks her to take a rest
for a few days and return to work with a
fresh mind after that marianne goes to
the mental asylum to meet mcvitty he yet
again asks her to kill manny before he
kills her before marianne can question
him further he leaves then she notices
that he was reading a book titled second
death it reminds her of one of manny's
drawings where he had depicted a man
falling off a building she realizes
something bad is about to happen to
mcvitty and runs outside but before she
can reach him he falls off the building
exactly like manny had predicted this
proves that manny is not a normal boy
which means kieran's life is also in
danger let's be real kieran's already
dead marianne panics and goes to
kieran's boat yet again she is scared
that if kieran gets on his boat he will
drown and die hence she unmoors the boat
away hoping to keep him from boarding it
and hence prevent his death then she
goes to the clinic and steals all of
manny's drawings from the archive to her
surprise everything that has happened to
her in the past has been vaguely
depicted in the drawings and she is
represented as the pig in all of them
one drawing in particular catches her
attention in which a man is asleep on a
sinking boat marianne realizes that it
is kieran who was probably asleep on the
boat that she unmoored in heavy rainfall
she runs to the side of the boat crash
and finds kieran's dead body being
brought out of the waters she had been
manipulated into making manny's
predictions come true marianne loses
control of herself and abducts manny
after the incident she points her gun at
him asking him to reveal his true
identity she thinks he is a messenger
sent by god to punish her because she is
an atheist they stop at a construction
building where marianne points the gun
at manny and asks him if she is still
being controlled by him many in turn
claims that she was the one who made
everything happen she opened the drawer
and the gun appeared and she was the one
who killed kieran having had enough
marianne shoots the kid dead and commits
the unthinkable right after in the
following scene she is in the hospital
after the car crash when she wakes up
her husband josh is by her side it turns
out that he survived the crash and only
she was hurt they returned home normally
unaware of everything that happened in
scotland but in the middle of the night
marian wakes up and tells josh she has
been to scotland before she thinks it
was a dream but remembers every detail
of the visit vividly she calls the
clinic the next day and hearing her
colleague's voice makes it clear that
the dream was true without informing
anyone she flies to scotland the next
morning and meets her colleagues however
they don't recognize her she asks them
about manny but they do not know him
either determined to know where he is
she goes to the archive room and finds
his files on the ground all of a sudden
manny appears from the dark and startles
her he says that he never changed the
future or manipulated her it was her who
made his predictions real by looking at
the drawings marianne takes a chance and
looks at the files again and finds a gun
inside she also finds a single drawing
that shows her josh's death which means
she has locked his fate by looking at
the picture she walks outside and
screams in frustration before the police
arrive and take her to a mental asylum
in the following scene manny comes to
visit her then something clicks in
marianne's mind she figures out that
manny needs her to fulfill his
predictions at the same time manny is
also inside the closet of his house he
is drawing yet another picture in which
he is visiting a pig in the hospital
like how he was with marianne earlier
after that we see marianne in a therapy
session she has finally found out the
meaning of her life and everything that
has been happening to her until now she
knows that she only exists in manny's
mind which is why he is able to change
and manipulate her future manny used to
be a happy child when his parents were
alive he had everything he wished for in
life but after the horrible death of his
parents he completely turned away from
reality he felt like nothing in his life
was in his control so he started to draw
it turns out that he created a false
reality in his art that he had complete
control over marianne is also a part of
this reality and is not a real person
this is why manny can make her do
anything and even send her to the past
marianne remembers him telling her that
he created her at the time she couldn't
figure out what it meant but now it is
crystal clear she looks up and says that
everything in the universe she is in
exists in the mind of a ten-year-old boy
back in actuality manny draws a final
picture of a pig telling the entire
truth to a therapist he finally lets go
of the false reality he created in his
mind and simultaneously the world around
marianne disappears in the end we see
manny hug his adoptive mother accepting
the reality of his parents death
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching